Hello Freak bitches.
We've got to be able to think more nuanced about these things and instead of
going,
well,
I don't trust Fox News,
therefore I don't trust any media.
Therefore I only am going to go to the site.
That keeps,
as you said,
reinforcing what I already believe.
Omg,
Gmos are horrible.com that's the only place where I get my news.
Well now you're in an echo chamber.
Yeah,
that's a huge issue.
And the other thing that you brought up there about political,
about financial,
all the different motivations,
all the different things and the variables,
that's also stuff that you have to try to pay attention to in squeeze into your
head.
And that's the thing.
It's impossible.
We need someone like you to sort of break it down.
Someone who has a background in this particular area to break it down in a way
that we can understand what we were.
Okay,
I'm comfortable.
The Cara Santa Maria is being honest with me about this particular aspect of
depression in neurochemistry.
He,
these are,
this is her experience.
This is also what she knows about the science behind it.
Right.
I have no motivation otherwise.
Nobody's paying me to say this.
And I think that this is why we,
as you know,
the listeners of the Joe Rogan experience,
the listeners of talk nerdy with Carrie Santa Maria,
the,
the people who are really involved in the next movement of,
um,
alternative and new media.
It is our responsibility to continue to support these kinds of programs and to
continue to speak up and become engaged and involved.
Because if we're not happy with the way that traditional media is handling
things because they're playing to the ratings and they're playing to the lowest
common denominator,
we can't be passive about it.
We have to support the news outlets and the organizations and the podcasts and
the web shows that,
that we support.
We have to do our part to make sure that those things don't fail because the
unfortunate thing is we don't have the backers that they have.
People look at someone posing with an African animal,
like a lion.
They,
they,
I think people look at it and they feel like they see a dead movie star
because they don't know like all you know of that animal is sort of wildlife
documentaries and then cartoon versions and the Lion King.
It's like,
you feel like you're looking at that.
But in America we drive down the road and we see just like contorted pulverized
deer carcasses.
Yeah.
You can't escape it.
Yes.
Yeah.
And so I feel like it's never going to be as offensive.
When someone sees a dead deer,
it's not as shocking to them is be like,
it's the animal from the movies.
Right.
And then killed it.
You know,
anthropomorphizing of an animal is a real issue when it comes really feels the
people more or less.
I remember a friend of mine who worked in the environmental movement,
or I shouldn't say that because she was a conservationist.
Okay.
This has worked in the conservation movement and she complained about,
um,
half jokingly about charismatic Megafauna,
so that so much mental of Americans gets tied up in the preservation of
charismatic megafauna.
And those things become such money sinks that we miss
opportunities to understand like this vast suite of other creatures out there
that doesn't make it onto calendars.
And she was,
I,
if I remember,
I think she was speaking of the amount of research dollars and dollars and
public interests and things that go into wolves like understanding wolves,
you know,
and there's all the other animals that she calls like non charismatic megaphone.
You just can't get someone
to like care about them.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'd say it's more chaotic now than it has been in recent memory.
I don't think,
I don't think that's a,
that's not a big statement
is that what happens is they'll just an ebb and flow when it comes to these sort
of situations.
When,
when it comes to like what's going on in the world,
power struggles and the power struggles that resolved and then new resistance
builds up.
I mean is that in your experience how things go?
Well,
I think it you,
you minimize the chaos by being consistent.
And what do I mean by that is,
is it,
you know,
and as foreign policy,
as an example,
if you're foreign policy message is consistent and uh,
and strong and clear and there's no misunderstanding by either your allies or
the people that,
uh,
that are against us,
then you can minimize the chaos that exists if it's not consistent and there's
confusion over where we stand.
And I'm saying we,
because you know,
okay,
fine,
we're still at the top of the,
of the food heap.
Whether people are comfortable with that or not,
I don't know.
But,
um,
so if,
if we're not consistent in that message,
then there's confusion and that's where you start to get problems cause you
started getting people probing at the perimeter,
trying to see what exactly is going on,
what they can get away with.
We start getting less leverage.
I mean,
you know,
we're getting situation in the Middle East now where countries are acting
completely without,
uh,
consulting,
with the u s you wouldn't have had that 30 years ago.
You know,
it just wouldn't happen.
What,
it's like Egypt.
Yeah.
Egypt and acting,
uh,
in,
in what they consider to be their own best interest.
The Saudis,
the Saudis are enormously pissed off at us still over of what they view as,
as the current administration is failure to,
um,
you know,
work with them to try to resolve some issues out in the Middle East and they
feel as if we've sort of abdicated responsibility now whether we have or not,
whether it's the right thing to do or not.
I'm,
I'm just saying from a policy perspective,
um,
you know,
if what we want to do is be isolationists then be very clear about that.
Say this is all we're going to do.
These are our parameters.
That's it.
So everybody knows good,
we're all good with it,
fine,
get on with it.
But you know,
the mixed messages or the problem,
I was selling masculine for a little while.
This guy,
this Guy Andre,
the blackest blacker than your coffee and tough and he was like in and out of
Juvie homes.
So he got me to sell it to my friends.
So I would have a bad cause like a lot of my friends were into the grateful dead
and we go to a dead shell and I would just sell like a hundred hits a masculine
and so uh,
so then one day I guess I didn't even owe him money.
Like he,
he would give me a bag and then I pay him after I sold it and time wasn't really
up yet.
But I came home one afternoon and I opened the front door to my house and I walk
in and we lived in a pretty nice house and my mom is sitting with Andre and the
living room having tea and she never met him.
She just,
he just showed up looking for me.
Oh.
And I was like,
oh what the fuck does uncomfortable that ended my,
my drug dealing days ended her right there.
Yeah.
You don't want Andrea embedded in your life.
Imagine if you can't,
we don't want a hundred is banging your mom.
Oh cause he would do that.
I know Andre and she's on mask.
I know Andrea.
I was going to do it.
Yeah,
he lit up or drink.
He had tea with her.
Dropped a tab under t right now the doors are playing riders on the storm and
you open the door and he's just fucking hammering your arm from behind.
Father.
Yes son.
I want to kill you
and to this house
Tonto.
Oh,
and you're like what?
And I walk in and he turns his head and sees me and he gives me a look that
makes me have to fucking leave the room.
It mid stroke doesn't even stop banging my mom.
Wow.
Yeah.
You don't want to see this.
I don't want to see that shit.
And I'm on mask.
Jedi mind trick too.
These are not the droids you're looking for
Andre.
Work in every angle.
It's someone like that banging your mom.
Oh that's dark.
Yeah,
that would be brutal.
That's dark.
Seeing his ass.
You know that prison ass.
You don't know what it's been through.
It's probably,
we've got stride and muscle tissue off out a two.
It looks terrifying.
Right?
Thank you.
Thinking about the amount of force he could generate without ass.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Strong thighs.
Cause he's walking around selling drugs.
He's out on the street.
It's that constant motion while cardio,
and now he's got the back of this size ripping and driving.
You know that drive you get from the inside of your thighs when you're real
fucking oh yeah,
he's doing that to her.
Oh,
good Lord.
is this Eric is actually,
no,
no.
We'll throw it.
We'll edit that part out.
Yeah.